écoutez le le sénateur retaillot a fini
son discours en disant il faut dire la
vérité aux Français et il ne cesse de
les de leur mentir quand il parle d'une
immigration incontrôlée c'est faux la
l'immigration est contrôlée en France
elle est à un rythme régulier quand il
parle d'appel d'air il a dû dire à peu
près 20 fois appel d'air il y a pas un
chercheur pas une enquête qui démontre y
compris que régulariser les travailleurs
sans papierers produit de l'appel d'air
quand il parle des sociodémocrates
Allemands pardon il y a qu'à regarder
les chiffres les Allemands accueillent
quatre fois plus de réfugié que la
France au regard de sa population par
rapport à la France aujourd'hui ils
veulent pas ils renvoient pas la
clandestinité les travailleurs en
Allemagne il leur propose la double
nationalité pour mieux les intégrer et
faire en sorte qu'il contribue
pleinement à la société et à l'économie
donc monsieur rotaillot est dans un
monde parallèle qui est un monde
politicien qui est un monde aujourd'hui
existentiel pour les républicains
c'estàd que s'il ne s'aligne pas sur
l'extrême droite ils ont peur de tomber
dans le macronisme les sondages récents
qui sortent sur ce projet de loi
immigration explicitent bien le fait que
les Français qui ont lu ce projet de loi
ils sont majoritairement favorables vous
l'avez lu vous le projet de loi ben oui
en l'occurence journaliste parlementaire
donc non mais vous l'avez lu le projet
de loi complètement vous l'avez lu il
est ici voilà donc il faut pas me dire
que les Français ont lu le projet de
loiurence en revanche si c'est pour ça
que on est un certain nombre nombreux à
avoir demandé cette convention citoyenne
sur l'immigration parce qu'on raconte
tellement de sotises sur ce sujet que
les Françaises et les Français ne savent
plus où on en est sur l'immigration
est-ce que quand on leur dit à ces
françaises et à à ces Français que ceux
qui les qui les soignent ceux qui
construisent leur bâtiment ceux qui
cuisin ceux qui les aident ceux qui
ramassent leur poubelles ceux qui
assurent leur protection sont parfois
des travails sans papier et ben je suis
convaincu que ils les ont applaudi
pendant la covid je suis convaincu
qu'ils sont pour leur
régularisation